when you take a look at the billionaires
list you'll see tech moguls
innovative geniuses real estate tycoons
business magnates
and then there is regular old warren
buffett
but here's why the simple man from
nebraska tops all of his peers
starting off warren buffett is likely
the most simple
and modest mega billionaire to this day
warren buffett lives in a house that he
bought way back in 1958
for thirty one thousand five hundred
dollars or about two hundred seventy six
thousand dollars
today since then the house has
appreciated to six hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
but that's actually still less than the
median house price in california
similarly he drives a very modest
cadillac xds which he bought in 2014
for 45 000 aside from this
the guy actually really enjoys eating at
mcdonald's
really the only extravagant purchase you
can find relating to warren buffett
is his private jet which he originally
named the indefensible
as he believed that the price value
ratio was extremely
not worth it nonetheless he did go ahead
with the purchase
and it does seem like it's grown on him
since as he now calls his private jet
the indispensable
anyways aside from that warren buffett
is still the most frugal mega
billionaire when it comes to day-to-day
life
as a private jet is not something he
uses on a daily basis
this is very surprising as though there
are also other top billionaires who live
well below their means
they always have a sweet tooth for one
toy or another
whether a 100 million dollar mansion or
an expensive car collection
but not only is warren buffett modest
when it comes to his own life
he is extraordinarily generous when it
comes to philanthropy
recently forbes released what they call
an enhanced philanthropy 400 score
essentially it rates each billionaire's
philanthropy on a scale from 1 to 10
based on how much they have how much
they have given and where they donated
to
and the highest philanthropy score
forbes has given out is a 5 out of 10
and only 10 billionaires received the
score
surprisingly warren buffett is the
richest billionaire by far to receive a
5 out of 10.
the second wealthiest billionaire to
receive such a score was gordon
and betty moore who boasts a fortune of
10.3 billion
to put this in perspective mark
zuckerberg has a philanthropy score
of 2 while jeff bezos and elon musk
actually have a philanthropy score of 1.
even bill
gates slightly falls short of warren
buffett with a philanthropy score
of four since 2006 warren buffett has
donated
a very generous 37 billion dollars in
fact
warren buffett would have 123 billion
dollars a day
if you factor in the amount he has given
away the only billionaire who beats him
out numerically
is bill gates who has donated 45.5
billion
looking forward warren buffett has no
plans to rein in his philanthropy
whatsoever warren buffett wants 90
of his wealth converted into index fund
holdings at the time of his death
and then he wants 99 of his wealth
donated to charity
with most of it going towards the bill
and melinda gates foundation
anyways being extremely modest and
charitable
are great personality traits but that
doesn't help one in actually becoming a
billionaire in the first place
that requires a whole other subset of
skills and traits
which warren buffett also excels in
here's the thing
most billionaires rely on a very
concentrated portfolio
with one maybe two companies and
they try to compound the holding as fast
as possible
through innovation and disruption this
is basically the case
with everyone at the top except warren
buffett
as he made his money through investing
as opposed to growing
his own company of course it could be
argued that berkshire hathaway
is the company that warren buffett grew
but
berkshire hathaway is really just a
holding company
and serves no function by itself in fact
if you look up how many employees
berkshire hathaway has you'll see a
massive
391 500 employees
however this number is misleading
as that includes all of the employees
that work in berkshire hathaway's
holdings
if we take a closer look at how many
people actually work at berkshire
hathaway corporate headquarters
we'll see that it's a very minimal 25
individuals
their staff is so small that everyone
can fit into a traditional
landscape photo with that being said
warren buffett
has been hands-on with his investments
from the very beginning
and he's been able to maintain steady
growth for decades
upon decades upon decades berkshire
hathaway has produced an astounding
average 20.5 annual return
since 1965. this means that
on average warren buffett has been able
to double his money
every four years for 55 years
to put that in perspective let's compare
it with the s p 500.
if you put in one thousand dollars into
the s p 500 in 1965
you would have a solid 200 000 today
which is a nice 200 x return if you bet
1 000
on warren buffett in 1965 however you
wouldn't have 2 million or
5 million or even 10 million but rather
27 million in other words your money
would have grown
27 000x at that rate
putting in just 40k would have made you
a billionaire today
over the past couple of years berkshire
hathaway
has struggled to beat the market but
this isn't because warren buffett lost
his touch or
anything like that rather berkshire
hathaway has grown so large
standing at over 500 billion dollars a
day
that they're essentially the market
themselves with that being said
when we're looking at wealth
accumulation and growth skills
warren buffett tramples his fellow
billionaires by far
after all warren buffett has maintained
an average 20.5
growth rate for longer than the entire
life spans of elon musk
mark zuckerberg larry page and sergey
brin
even jeff bezos is only one year older
than buffa's growth streak
so if you were going to bet on who would
be most successful
at replicating the results from zero
warren buffett
would likely be the safest bet moving on
we have a crystal clean track record the
companies of everyone at the top
have received several black marks from
the public apple
is greedy profit hungry pigs microsoft
has a notorious
history with copying software facebook
and google
sell personal information and all energy
and manufacturing companies pollute the
environment
meanwhile berkshire hathaway doesn't
really have a black spot
for things such as labor exploitation or
meager pay
of course they have invested in
companies with some of these black marks
but for the most part berkshire
hathaway's investments are very
non-offensive
this is because generally warren buffett
stays away from tech stocks and
revolutionary companies
other than apple growth stocks aren't
warren buffett's favorite
and he has found most of his success
within value stocks
and the thing is value stocks are
generally
stocks of companies that we use and see
on a daily basis
and though we may very well enjoy their
products we don't have an overly
positive
or negative attitude towards the brand
companies like coca-cola
american express visa craft heinz
costco and procter gamble warren buffett
has takes
in all of these companies and many more
like them
evidently most of warren buffett's
investments lay in everyday brands
that we don't really hate or love which
makes this what
uncontroversial for the most part next
up
warren buffett has always been open with
all of his investments
his wealth and his gratefulness warren
buffett has often bragged that he pays a
lower tax rate than his secretary
but this isn't some sort of secret
operation
warren buffett publicly releases his tax
returns on a regular basis
and encourages everyone to look into his
tax returns
and see if they can find any flaws with
them aside from this
warren buffett is very aware of
advantages that he may have had
as he grew up and he often attributes a
lot of his success to these favorable
circumstances
anyways finally the last major reason
that warren buffett is the king of them
all
is because he leaves a legacy and a path
that his followers can replicate
for themselves all investors know warren
buffett's two rules of investing
which are number one never lose money
and number two
never forget rule number one similarly
he has many other famous stock investing
lessons as well
such as it's far better to buy a
wonderful company
at a fair price than a fair company at a
wonderful price
he even has four full books detailing
his investment journey
which many people have been replicating
for decades
and will continue to do so moving
forward now of course
these individuals aren't all
billionaires like warren buffett
but that's not really the criteria to
determine whether or not following the
same investment philosophy
was successful sure the average value
investor following warren buffett's
advice
likely will not receive a 27 000 x
return
but what about a tenth of that or even a
hundredth of that
in the end warren buffett's investing
philosophies can be applied by the
average person
to get at least decent results
unfortunately
this is not the same case with other
billionaires
elon musk always preaches the importance
of hard work
and he's absolutely right but the truth
is
working 22 hours a day is likely not
going to lead to you
launching a rocket in 20 years and
dropping out of harvard
isn't going to result in microsoft or
facebook 2.0
as a result though innovators like elon
musk and steve
jobs are admirable and inspirational
from a distance
their journeys are not very applicable
to our personal lives
with warren buffett on the other hand
doge's principles are again
unlikely to land you a spot as one of
the greatest investors of all time
they are likely to help you grow your
own personal fortune to multiple
millions
if not tens of millions at the end of
the day
warren buffett is the most modest of the
billionaires
one of the most charitable of the
billionaires has by far
the longest track record amongst
billionaires is one of the most moral
and transparent billionaires and his
legacy
is the most applicable to the average
person and
that's why i believe he's the
billionaire to follow
do you guys admire warren buffett
comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys will be
using his principles to grow your own
fortune
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari
and i'll see you guys on the next one